Kim Kardashian opens up about Kylie's
slit from Tyga Taylor Swift and her
marriage to Kris Humphries I love that
the 36 year old reality star was a guest
on Sundays watch what happens live where
she laid it all out on the table
admitting she knew her 2011 marriage to
Kris Humphries would fail : 30 years old
I better get this together I better get
married but I knew like honeymoon it
wasn't gonna work out my wife she's
walking down the aisle Kim even
subjected herself to plead the fifth and
confessed to being happy about her
little sister split from boyfriend Tyga
and what was great was that they just it
was so easy that that split they just
you know there's an has not been any
drama like it with her and momager Kris
Jenner will only be speaking to
ex-husband Pete when Jenner for one of
two reasons Kendall and or Kylie stop
Kim also revealed whether or not she
spoken to Taylor Swift since all the
drama went down after Kim seemingly
exposed her on snapchat over husband
Kanye West's song famous I made that
famous any contact since then no
you